Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David Flanagan, although you'll know
me as Rawkode,
and there's a nice big articular area as
I took this arm.
Thanks. This is custard. We have two great
teams today competing,
trying to affect each other's sabotage and broken
cluster. Now, we get started with that, I
do just need to say hello and thanks
to our sponsors.
So first up, we have Teleport. We've been
using Teleport on clusters since the very beginning.
It's how we secure access to the servers.
It's how we collaborate and pair on the
debug session and fixing these clusters. And it's
just an absolutely wonderful tool that I genuinely
believe every kind of Google cluster should have
installed. So go check it out. It's
just the best product. I'm so happy with
it. I also wanna thank Equinix Metal. I
see all the comments in the chat. I'll
get to use in a second.
I also wanna thank Equinix Metal. They provide
all the hardware that we use on Clustered.
We go through six
heavy duty bare metal machines every single week
with tons of cores, tons of RAM. Why?
Well, because it makes it more fun. So
thank you to Equinix Medal.
Alright. Let's jump over to our first team
of the day. We have
team Kong.
Hi there. How are you both?
Good. Good. Good. Alright. Well, thanks having us.
No. No. It's my pleasure. Definitely. And I've
got alarms going off. Like, it this is
just the challenge we've been in the middle
of a random industrial estate. However, we'll we'll
just ignore that. Could you please both say
hello, introduce yourselves, and then we'll get started
with today's session?
Yeah. Sure. I'll go first. My name is
Kat Morgan. I am
with Kong.
Colin and I are both joining from Kong.
I am in the Pacific Northwest US and
happy to be here to see if I
could actually live up to expectations
trying to solve this cluster stuff.
It's madness. It's all madness.
Colin?
Thanks, Kat. Yeah. My name is Colin Loader.
As Kat said, we're both from Kong. We're
field engineers within Kong, so we
are kind of, like, in the professional services
side of things, help out customers with issues
they have with Kong.
I came from both Red Hat and VMware,
working more on the Kubernetes side. So been
in the Kubernetes
work for the last few years. So, yeah,
excited to see what the
what the the breaks that we have are
that we need to fix. It's gonna be
fun. Awesome. Thank you both for sharing. Well,
your cluster was broken by team ARMOR. They
will be joining us later to the cluster
that you have prepared for them. I am
going to pop up my screen share here,
and I am going to give you access
to the clusters.
So I'm gonna audit a change or a
common rule
And now you have access.
Nice and simple.
So I will open the first session on
the armo control plane. If you could please
both use the activity page
and active sessions, join the one at the
bottom. And if you could just do me
a favor and type echo hello or anything
so that I know you're in here and
then we will get things underway.
Alright.
Like, we're flying already.
Alright. I wish you the best of luck.
I can encourage you to export your cube
config, set up any aliases that you need,
and check for the control plane. Best of
luck.
Alright.
Straight into t mux.
No. I I'm gonna use that muscle memory
and be mad if it's not there. So,
Colin, do you wanna drive first or you
want me to dive in?
Sure. Yeah. I can let me start some
stuff. Let me just add some completions and
whatnot first.
And
if we get it, I also will mess
up if I don't have that. Yep. And
I think this is the right syntax.
Q t p l k, I believe.
Alright.
And then we can take.
I didn't know you could set up the
auto complete for the k. That's pretty cool.
Oh, yeah. It's a lifesaver. Oh, it's admin.com.
It's not.
And also Kubernetes. Kubernetes.
Alright.
So let's see, see what we have first.
Alright. K. Well, we have a lot of,
a lot of restarts. That's always fun
for both the app and Postgres. Alright. What
do you wanna check first, Kat?
We can go ahead and check events in
the namespace if we want to.
Alright. Liveness probes. That's
easy enough.
Ready That's that's a bold statement right off
the back. Yeah. That's actually yeah. So I
probably shouldn't say that. But
okay. So liveness and readiness.
I'm gonna check the deployment.
Let's see.
Deployment.
Clustered.
Alright. So
we have for liveness probe,
slash health on eighty eighty.
Don't look bad to me, but
I believe they're okay.
Okay.
Billing thresholds look okay.
Alright. Well, I do see something already.
Yeah. It's just the virus. CPU.
I I don't like that.
Okay.
I mean, there's a rust application, but it
doesn't require a lot of resources.
So I'd say That's a lot of faith
in that application.
Alright. This Equinix metal better really hold up.
Okay.
So let's start with getting rid of those.
Are you are you just gonna delete out
the limits?
I sure
Who needs limits? Yeah. Who needs resource limits?
Just remove
them.
Okay.
So let's see what's what what that does.
Okay. Well,
that's better ish. Seems happier. Yeah.
But we didn't see we didn't see anything
for the
Postgres pod on events.
I yeah. I didn't see it.
Because that's all on the cluster pod. Okay.
Well,
one thing we can check,
what are these
this is on Port 30000.
Right? Yes. Port. Okay.
Okay. Well, we can at least connect to
the app. Obviously, we know that database connection
is gonna be not good now since we're
not check? Would you like me to open
it? Just
Sure. Yeah. Yeah. We can see the That'd
be fine. The image.
This is the RML cluster. Right?
Hey, Colin. Can I check and see what
pods the
or what nodes our pods are on? See
if they're on the same nodes or not?
Yeah. Absolutely.
Alright. Connection
with you.
They are on different nodes. Oh, wait. I
don't know. We might
Yeah. That's that's something definitely to check.
So we can look at I assume this
is a deployment as well.
Postgres as a stateful state. Stateful state. Yeah.
Alright.
What is in here?
So I don't see a problem with the
health checks.
Not yet.
Okay. Let's keep going.
Health.
Let's
one thing we might check next is our
storage to see if there's a PVC available.
Defaulting to this. I don't know. I didn't
actually see So the one is being used.
There's no CSI configured. No persistent volumes. I
used it. That's right. That's right. Okay. It's
an empty Dir Postgres.
Okay. Okay. Got it.
Maybe something else in here that is
off.
Yeah. So I don't see anything here, so
maybe it's not that. Can you
Can check
our actually,
I was just wondering if the image I
didn't check the spelling and stuff on the
image if that's there or not.
I I think it was okay. It looks
like it was just the Postgres
13.
13 outbound. That looks okay.
Yep. Looks good. Think.
No. No. That looks good. I assume that's
the default.
I mean, we can see if there's any
doubt that this is gonna have any logs.
So the thing that you're debugging right now
I mean, I pulled up the page. So
just make sure you're working on the right
header here.
Server connection timed out. I mean, I think
we have to get past this since the
it it's not even started.
Okay.
But I guess if it is timing out,
that does point to a network issue as
well.
Kat, do you have any ideas or anything
else you wanna check?
Yeah. Let me jump into
So your post guys pod is crash lit
back off. What does that mean?
Something's preventing it from starting.
Preventing it from starting?
Well, that that means it's not running or
it it's not
passing liveness. So But it was
running and now it isn't. Maybe
log?
Actually, we might
here.
So if we do that
Navin Kumar is saying, check the log.
Okay. So we should have
You'd be surprised how often that actually fix
these things on clustered. Just delete them.
Usually quite effective.
Can can we look at the logs cap
for that? Yeah.
Hang on. I
think I've been relying a little too much
on Lens lately,
and my cuddle is a little rusty for
debugging.
Okay. Bad in its script. That's interesting.
We could check that.
There's no. They wouldn't have changed because we
don't have persistent.
The command could have been
edited by chance.
So the way the Postgres works on custard
is there is
conflict map mounted into the container,
which is put into a special There is
a conflict map. That Postgres will load.
Is it as easy as getting rid of
the
echo and the exit?
I mean,
those look suspicious. Right?
They do to me.
Yeah.
Oh, well, yeah, there's no test unit test
on them.
Alright. It's looking a little better if it
comes up.
Well, that's two weeks in a row we've
had people attack pull squares, which is the
first two times we've ever had anyone attack
Postgres,
believe it or not. It's getting popular then.
Alright. So
David, do you mind checking to see if
it's at least connecting to the database now?
It looks like it is on the curl,
but okay. So it looks good. You've got
the the watch tab. So yeah.
Alright. So
let's
go for editing the deployment then for cluster
then just change it to v two. I
assume it's not gonna be that easy, but
try it.
Oops. Sorry.
Oh, you're good.
And it should be seconds ago.
It's does that doesn't look good to me.
It's still watch tap.
So v one. The curl will show you
the file name and the title.
Yep. V one and v one. So yes.
Alright. So let's take a look at that
pod and
just verify that it is
if it's changing it back to v one
or
if we have bigger problems.
Okay. So just changing it back to v
one.
But it's v two That one's fine.
So that
feels like it's
does that seem like a mutation to you?
Can we check that?
Go for it.
I don't know what the CRD name is.
Yeah. Carlos in the chat. It's not a
CRD, but The mutation webhook.
It's a mutating webhook
configuration. Mutating webhook?
Oh, there it is. Okay.
There's a Cilium one.
Let's see what's in there.
Failure policy.
I
Is that the whole thing?
Yeah. I think so. That's all I see.
What are you thinking?
I don't know for sure. I would say
that that's probably not real.
But it's called Solium.
You think they have a sneaker n as
their real name?
Yes.
Oh, we haven't, like, been looked at labels
yet.
Alright. So you don't think the web hook
is real. What's your options?
Delete it and break the cluster more.
Investigate it.
I'm
wondering
so
I know that
I know that in
registries.com,
if you can create aliases and things like
that,
That would be on the worker nodes themselves
if we were doing that, though.
What do you think the aliases are doing?
Go back to.
What's that, Colin?
I kinda wanna go back to the to
that webhook, though, because I I mean, I
don't know
I don't work with these a lot, so
I I don't know for sure. But, like,
I don't like this URL thing. I kinda
wanna see what's what's there.
Curl it.
Okay.
Not allowed for this. Okay.
Python.
Oh, okay. Python application
and root stuff Kubernetes webhook example.
Yeah. I I don't feel like this is
good, like, a real thing. So
I'm
I'm just leaning towards deleting that webhook, to
be honest.
Go for it. I encourage it. We can
we can we can save it off if
we wanted to first. But, yeah, if we
would just wanna live crazy,
let's go for let's delete it.
I guess so. I'm happy to confirm that.
I don't think n as in Cilium is
written in Python. So
Yeah. That seems weird to me. That's true.
Okay. I'm deleting this.
Alright. Do we want us to smash
our pod again, or do we need to
I don't yeah.
Yeah. I'm gonna delete that and have it
pull a new one and see if the
image has changed.
We need to flip the cluster d pod,
not the post cross pod.
Oh, yeah. Right. Sorry.
Okay.
Just delete all. Delete dash dash all. I
mean,
what bad thing ever happened from deleting all
the parts in our namespace?
Now.
David, do you mind checking
Happy tip. The browser.
Okay. Alright. That's not a good sign.
That's funny, though.
That's awesome.
Nice work, team Arvo. Nice work.
Very well done. Makes me think that
it is messing with the
container d. The image.
Yeah. So because it's the correct well, sensibly,
it's the correct URL
to the image.
Yeah.
So we can go ahead and jump over
to
the worker node that that's scheduled on
Yep. And jump into our registries.com
for starters.
So they're both on worker two.
K.
David, do you mind creating a session for
worker two?
Armour
worker.
Alright.
Okay.
I
do not remember where that lives. Is it
let's see.
No. I think I can find it.
Okay. Go for it.
Oh, snap. The ARMOR team are laughing in
the chat. It's just FYI.
Alright. That's fine. Well, actually, there is a
good point. Local image which is used. I
didn't check to see what the Wait. Policy
was. But
Oh, shush. That's
a good
call.
We could just change it to always just
to be safe.
Do what?
We could change the image pool policy to
always just to be safe, make sure it's
not using a local I believe it was
always the last time you edit Oh, was
deployment at least.
Okay.
You can check, but I'm I'm pretty confident
I did see it.
This is
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. So, yeah, we'll need to
probably look at the history. In that case,
I'm going to
or
because we're not running see, I'm coming from,
like, OpenShift mindset where there's, like, an image
stream policy stream
craziness,
but this is not OpenShift.
So
I wasn't getting yeah. So
there should be a registries.com,
But it's not where I was thinking to
find it. I think that may be an
OpenShift centric thing. What
does Redshift.com
do with OpenShift? And I'll see if I
can correlate it back to Cube admin.
Okay.
So
well, on I know on cryo that registries.conf
gives you
the ability to, like, set insecure registries and
but maybe it's in container d Yeah. But
I'm not finding any container directory.
No Etsy container directory.
Yeah. So container d does allow you to
dump its config,
which would show you if there were any
aliases in that regard.
Okay.
So I can't remember the exact So tag.
But I think it's container. Learn container d?
If you run container d dash dash help,
it should give you what you needed.
But there's a, yeah, config dump as Okay.
That's the container d as a default.
Yeah. Yeah. Because, likely, they haven't configured container
d in that way.
Oh, wait. It's just config. Yes. Update. Config.
Yeah.
And then dump.
So that filter with TOML means they have
not tweaked container d in any way with
fake registry. So it's just running normal. Okay.
Yeah.
So if they're not pulling a fake image
in place,
what other options out there?
Yeah. That wouldn't have worked any I don't
know. Why don't you confirm something? Can you
exec into the cluster pod and curl local
host?
Yeah.
Oh, sorry. Colin, go for it. Oh, sorry.
Do you jump into the other container?
Yeah. You need to jump into the cluster
pod, which does have,
I believe, s h available.
Oh, okay.
I don't think it's slash s h, so
we'll just try. And
Carl should be there.
8080?
80.
Oh, what we see here is video v
two. Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. So
so
I don't know what can
The pod looks alright. Oh, unless it's
But if I if we browse to DNS.
Yeah.
We get that.
Wait a minute. You
is it
Okay.
The image is fine. The pod workload is
fine. A curl to that IP address on
that port is not fine.
So the cluster service runs as a node
port on port 30,000.
I would maybe start there.
Okay. Like, is my service still configured correctly?
I guess you're in the control plane. Yeah.
Oh, yeah. I'm sorry. That's alright. I'll keep
up.
Looks alright.
So how else would it be sending traffic
somewhere else?
I'm sitting here thinking of all the ways
that, like,
an ingress controller could do all of this
stuff, but, obviously, we don't have that in
play.
So we haven't looked to see we've only
looked at the default workspace. We haven't actually
seen what else is
running in other places. Fair. Well, we could
check, yeah, other services.
There are heads as well if required.
Is it just me or is the TMUX
very small? Yeah. I just had to kinda
jump around. I think the TMUX is causing
some dying. Issues. Oh, if you resize your
window just a little bit, it'll refresh the
the TMUX frame. Okay.
So we're gonna do
is there anything else?
No.
Okay.
So I think that hint is for the
webhook.
Maybe it should be a hint one or
two. Yeah.
Yeah. I think each one's referencing a different
thing, but
so labeling things is not nice. We haven't
done anything with labels yet, but no.
I think number one is the
yeah. Don't know.
Those are those are very subtle hints. They're
correct when they said that. Right? So
It's one thing to live and other things
to answer.
Oh, okay. So hence one is subtle hints,
but for this four different problems.
Right. So okay. Each one
Okay. And then each. So it's a yeah.
A series of
related hints.
So those two middle ones seem relevant. Who
owns has the right to answer, and it's
one thing to live and another to answer.
So our pod is alive
and running, and we verified it, but it's
not answering
the HTTP request.
So I think that one had to do
with the the limits that were set because
that's the the same
number in each of those. It's like the
it is tight here. I can't remember. That
has to do with the limits. So I
think that one's it, but it's the second
one that we need.
So everything has to do with Kates.
Python Python is everywhere.
Oh, not everything has to do with Kubernetes.
But
Yeah.
So how does
node port work? If we're seeing that any
request to this IP address Oh. For that
port gets re registered to the service. We
could
well, the pod wouldn't
start if something else was listening on that
port that was not in Kubernetes.
Well, the pod isn't exposing a high port
number.
I think you're onto something there. K.
Alright.
Can see what else is running. Alright. I'm
on the worker.
Oh, next steps coming up.
Alright.
No. 830000
is the port we're worried about just now.
That's right. Sorry.
More Python. Okay.
I'd say it's probably pretty safe to kill
that process.
Yeah.
Okay.
Straight in with a sick kill.
Hope it's not supervised.
Alright. How's our
service looking now? Have a look.
You got the dance.
Much better. There we go.
Alright.
That was That was fun. That was Those
are cool. That was really fun. We have
ten minutes left. Well done.
See? Good fun. Right?
That was that was really good. What I'm
curious about is do you think you have
been meaner?
You know what?
First,
Colin, virtual high five.
Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah.
Alright.
And now I'm nervous if we've been too
mean.
I don't know.
We'll find out in a couple minutes. Alright.
Well I
Sorry to go. Yeah.
No. No. Okay. Well
well done. You both absolutely smashed that. So
thank you for joining me. I'm going to
say goodbye and invite the ARMOR team to
come on and see what Team Kong have
for us to debug. So thank you again.
Great job, and I'll speak to you both
soon. Thanks. Bye. Yep. Thanks, David. See you.
Alright. So, Armour, please come on and join
us.
Great breaks there. That gif is gonna have
me laughing
for a long, long time.
And let's get our sessions ready.
Alright.
Hey, Ben.
Hi. How are you doing? Nice guess.
Yeah.
That that was funny. Hope you like this.
Yeah. That was funny. Very well done.
Some good breaks there. I like that a
lot.
And we've got some more teammates joining there.
Oh, there we go.
Alright.
Hello. Hi. How are you? Doing very well.
Thank you. Thank you for joining us. I
think we're just waiting on one more.
And then we'll start the introductions, get you
access to the Kong Cluster,
and then we'll see how that goes.
Are you impressed with Team Kong?
They did a great job. Very nice.
Wow.
Wow. That was awesome.
Okay. So there is a problem with login.
Wait a second. I haven't given you access
yet. Wait a second for
let's check her check with her.
Yeah. She said
she's she's saying she has problems with login.
Wait
a second. I think that she's using the
not the right
link.
Alright.
Alright. Well, while we wait, I will just
enable access to
the cluster. So I'm gonna edit the role
for team armo.
Okay. Rawkode is moving to to different
machine.
She's going to be with us within a
few Yeah. No worries. Seconds. We're all good
here.
Oh, we're trying to calm control plan one.
So I have opened a session. If you
all just want to use activity active sessions
and join, type echo hello to let me
know that you're there. And then when we
have a full team, we will get the
introductions underway.
Okay.
So this is the last one. Right?
Which one is it?
Control plane one. So you go to the
very bottom of the list.
So activity,
active sessions, and then at the very bottom,
you will see a con control plane one
session.
Awesome.
And I will join it too.
Because sometimes VEM looks a bit weird on
the CLI.
Oh, no. We have multiple sessions because I
have no joint one that isn't my one.
I would I tried the last one.
Oh,
yeah. It's it's not the last one. It's
Oh, okay. Control plane one.
Yeah. Yeah. I guess. I think someone just
accidentally started a new session, which threw it
off a little bit. But yeah.
I think we Wait a second.
Wait a second. Okay. So I I I
see one that where
You should see Rawkode,
hello world, Rawkode echo.
Yeah. David,
my
you told me you are in the wrong
you are in the wrong one. Sorry. Oh,
I'm in the wrong one. Okay.
Yeah. Go to the go to active sessions
in under activity.
Right. I'm under activity. There's cong worker two.
That's the last one of the list. Yes.
So the one before that is cong control
point one. Let's jump onto that one. I
think there's a few active sessions.
Few which is open for two minutes.
You see me?
Yeah. You are not in the right one.
I
mean,
at least on the control plane one.
Yeah. Yeah. But you're opening your own session
instead of joining a session. Yeah. Yeah. So
when
just go exit this this session. Okay? And
go to active sessions. You should see which
users are in each session, and you should
see David as Rawkode,
We have slash Ben.
Okay. Mhmm. This one here. Here
we go.
I'll just close all the other sessions open
here.
Yeah. I'm gonna have to start restarting teleport
before we go live.
Alright. Let's start the introductions just now.
We'll start with you Ben and then we'll
just work our way around. Please feel free
to say hello, tell us a bit about
yourself and then I will get you onto
this cluster.
Yeah.
Hi, everyone. I I'm Ben from Armo,
managing the engineering here. We are the maintainers
of CubeScape,
and, you know, we came here to have
fun.
Awesome. Thank you.
That's true.
Alright.
Whoever wants to go next, David, Rawkode.
Yeah. So I'm David. Also I work in
Armour, and I'm also here to have fun.
Let's let's see what what is waiting for
us. Oh, here we go. I found it.
Okay.
Yeah. I I finally logged in.
Oh, welcome.
Yeah. Thanks.
I'm Rawkode. I'm also from our team,
and
we're all very fun people. So I also
want to help them.
So that's about it. We like gifts.
Yeah.
We have Patel here as well.
Hi. I'm from.
And I'm here to a lot of fun.
Alright. Thank you all.
But I think we are now all on
the same session, so I'm going to bring
my screen share back. I would encourage you
to set up any aliases, configure the Kube
config, and check the control plane and best
of luck.
Okay.
David, do you want to start?
Yeah. I can start if you want. Let's
see with the copy paste work over here.
Why not?
Oh,
not real.
Not really. One second.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, it's this.
Let's
see. Are we are we? I think Yeah.
Are we in dashboard? Yeah.
It's batch.
What was your command that you did?
Yeah. Oh, we have we have tried.
Okay.
I
think the first you have just to export
the cube config. Oh, we need to export
the kube config. You
Export kube config.
Okay. And And it's e
t slash e t c.
Yeah. You saw it there.
And
And Kubernetes.
This is Alright.
Give me a sec. We're losing time. Yeah.
You can take it. Here.
What's with the Oh, I think I think
you found your first Yeah.
Yeah. I think this is a might be
the issue.
Okay. Okay. So we have alias.
Check for alias.
Let's see.
Echo.
No.
Let's try this.
Okay. Now
just write
You can just run the alias command to
list aliases. Yeah. Just yeah. Write alias.
Okay. It's not that?
No. That's okay. I don't see here anything.
K.
Let me try something. Okay?
Sure. Go for it.
Okay.
Nice. Sure. Yes. I told
yeah.
Try where it's Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. No. It's okay. We are removing
removing games.
Nice games, by the way.
Yeah.
Very funny.
Oh, wait. Should I copy paste for you?
Oh, here we go. Yeah. It's it's fun.
Are you going to look inside the file
at least?
Mhmm. Oh, okay. Here we go. Oh, this
also explains the auto complete.
It it does did.
No.
It's it's still not
it it's still not Let's try where is
keeps keep CTL. Wait
a second. Let me there's shrinking.
No.
That that it's still not the one.
So,
yeah, it's usually
Let's try.
Echo.
What what do we have here?
Okay.
What
a mean thing to do.
Let's try Oh, because it no. Because it's
returned it from the bash RC. Sorry.
So or somewhere.
Wait a second.
Let's see. You could always absolute path your
kube control.
Yeah. That's Another option another option is to
overwrite the what they put over there nears
the games and just to copy there the
kube CTL.
That's a good idea. Yeah. That's that's a
good idea. Let's try doing that. This will
probably solve it pretty quickly. L l slash
user local
game.
Where is the real one?
Try let's try where is kubectl,
the command of where is.
Where is?
Yep.
Kubectl.
Okay. Great. So we have user local as
bin kubectl. Let's move
let's let's let's see p to user games.
Come on. Let's at least look at user
games kubectl.
Open it in Vendor.
Okay. S bin. In curiosity. Oh,
let's see what yeah. Let's see if this
works.
Did they What do mean? Oh, they they
maybe changed the name of the binary. That
also that's also possible.
Yeah. But, also, it's usually fine. Not not
nothing has been.
So the
cat from
ThemeKong has asked if help is actually helpful.
Or maybe maybe
kubectl help will give you a hint. Oh,
that's interesting.
Okay. Kubectl help. Let's see what happens.
Oh, maybe we have over there another joke.
Or we download simply. We we should install
Deepgram from scratch.
Well, let's look at the script. Come on.
Let's I wanna know what I've done.
Oh, okay.
You're saying it back. Yeah. I mean, Kat
and it seems a bit brave, but go
for it.
What why you say it's crazy? You said
you thought it was a script.
Okay. Ascii. That was good. You can catch
it. Yeah. That that's a
yeah.
Okay. Oh, it's
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. No. It's funny. Now let's
see let's see what the echo from.
So it's from kubectl
they oh, they simply just let's
see. No. Okay. Now the other kubectl
let's see what the other kubectl is.
Yeah. In in user local has been.
I'm assuming that's possibly the same. Right?
Yeah. So
I would download, David, the I would download
simply the the
the root of KubeCTL.
Okay. Let's do that. Download
KubeCTL.
Yeah. Zero trust Kubernetes. That's what we need.
Yeah.
So
then you want me to do it? Well,
whatever. Just copy kubeCTL
to where the in this game directory.
Let's continue with the nice game directory.
Yeah.
Let the games begin.
Are you using it?
Downloading it. Let's see.
Wait a second.
Oh, are you are you also?
No. Wait a second. Someone has put something
here. Let me try something. Okay? Cool. Sure.
Okay. Get pods.
Mods.
Okay.
That's better. Okay. So this is great. Okay.
This is this is something. Okay. Now Right.
I Now let's copy this.
Let now let's copy Chip CTL to the
games. Right?
Okay.
That's
okay.
So
it's not connecting the API server.
Right. We need to find the cube the
cube config file.
Okay. Right? K.
Have the
kube config where it is. It is sequence
admin config.
That's what we can that's what we can
figure.
Let's try to
David, let's let's try sorry?
How about just
let's say, is it over here? What is
it possible they put it here?
Cube.
I'm not sure though. Why do you think
that it's not right? I mean, the IP
Oh.
Yeah. It may just be there's no API
server running. Have you checked that? Yeah. Yeah.
The yeah. So let's let's first of check
if with NetStats whether it is running.
Right. Okay. So just NetStats
are you writing?
NetStats? I thought you were writing. Are you
writing? Okay.
Go ahead. Something is wrote.
What is it? T u n
l p. Right?
Rev six.
Not really running something. Something Did you mean
8414?
Oh. Kubelet is running.
Kube VIP is running. Salesforce is running,
but no API server is running. So let's
just
check one more thing.
API.
No. Definitely not running. You
can definitely not running. So
the API server isn't running,
and, obviously, this is not so good.
So we need to bring up the API
server.
This
is the time you need to say how
we are bringing up your our API servers.
Let's think.
So I I'm sure that it was
putting up the counter plan with Kube admin.
Yep. These are Kube admin clusters. Definitely.
Okay. So
I don't know The kube admin uses static
manifest for
the control plane component,
which are in let's say Kubernetes manifest.
Yeah.
It was in its right
to put up the the control plane
and
manifest. Yeah.
Let's look to let's look for the manifest.
Let's let's let's look for the manifest maybe.
Yeah. I would go to Etsy Kubernetes manifest
and see what you've got.
Mhmm.
There is something is wrong with my browser.
Slash
f c d
Kubernetes.
Right. Okay. We have admins kind of manifest.
QAPI
server. API server.
Great. You wanna let's let's take a quick
look. And if it looks okay, yeah, let's
let's just supply this.
Yeah. Do
some of you know how we are supplying
to kubeadmin?
Yeah.
So kubeadmin monitors this directory and the kubel
the kubelet monitors this directory and will attempt
to deploy anything inside of it.
So you don't need to run any kube
admin commands.
So
you're saying
you don't need to run. The question is,
who's who should we bring this up? Because
I didn't see Kubelden running on this machine.
The Kubelden is responsible for bringing them up.
Oh, the Kubelden is The Kubelden. Yeah.
Kubelet kubelet conf.
I see here
configuration of kubelet,
bootstrap
Mhmm. Container.
I I think it there should be a
static pods here
somewhere.
Maybe you wanna try to keep it config?
Yeah.
Oh, it should be
Kubernetes.com.
It's in Varlib. Here.
We are not in oh, sorry. We're not
in the first directory.
Okay.
So let's see the file.
Control plane.
Service.
Check the varlib. Let's config.
Let's see if we see there anything.
I think that's good advice.
That's Rawkode's idea.
Which one?
The var lib kubelet config. Yeah. The lib
kubelet
config.
Yeah.
Let's see.
K.
Authorization.
There is some parameter there that is Static
bot path seems right.
Yep. Looks okay.
Volume streams also shut
down then. It is time out. Notes.
Alright. And the static static pod pod path
also looks okay.
Right? Manifests. Yep. It is Kubernetes manifests.
We have a comment from Russell on the
chat highlighting that there may be a small
error
with an s on the end. What was
the directory called under Etsy Kubernetes?
Manif manifest
or manifest?
Oh my god. I
don't know what is the right one, by
the way, for savings. As long as they
match, you're you're all good.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know what causes the queue. Should
we restart the Qubelet?
Yeah. It's a system deserviced, so you both
have to
to restart.
System STL.
System CTL.
Yeah. System
CTL
service
cube
kubelet.
Restart. Mhmm.
And that's your system five stuff coming out.
System control restart Kubelet.
System control.
Too many edit systems. Yeah.
Delete the service. Yeah. And then the Yeah.
And restart
Why?
This is attempt where I was working with
Ubuntu.
Fingers crossed.
That looks better. Much
better. Okay.
Very nice. Team team Kong, very nice. Well
done.
Okay.
Sir, reject a request for unknown
reason. Let's
look for okay. Let's try events.
Let's try We are we are not talking.
We are not talking. Oh, this is a
bad request. Try get pod minus v
minus v equals six.
Yeah.
I know, but I don't I'm not sure
that this is the issue.
We have an issue. Let's see. Here we
go. This shows us exactly what we requested.
Just
go upload it from
here we go. I think that dash v
six was an absolutely great idea.
I think you've got
Here, it couldn't get let's see. Body was
not decodable, unable to check for status.
I'll get version kind.
Okay. So the object that's returned Client sent
an h t h t p request to
an h t p server, again with the
s, I think.
Same issue. Okay. So go go to the
kube config, David.
Go to kube config.
Okay.
Russell in the chat is asking what is
the dash v syntax.
So dash v followed by a number will
give you for boss a logging from one
till nine. No. No. Not not here. Not
to to the /etc/etc/tc/etc
Kubernetes
admin
I see. Admincom.
Yeah. Yeah. Here we exactly. That's the problem.
The HTTP needs an I love it when
the cursor starts in the right place.
Yeah. Yeah.
Dude, HTTP
s s.
You're in you're in
yeah. You're
you're in the wrong mode. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm getting out of there.
Let's do it again.
Hi.
There we go. Nothing wrong.
Yeah.
That's it. Okay. So retry kubectl again.
Let's try again. Get pods.
Okay. Okay. Nice. Now this is sending less
wires to sending.
May want some less verbosity there.
Yeah.
So an s miss s is missing also.
You think that went for a theme, Ben,
just removing all the s's?
Yeah. So I think that from now on,
every time I get another from the our
production, I'm going to look for s's.
It's actually not a bad idea.
Yeah.
Clustered.
Alright. These are halfway through. So we got
a whole twenty two minutes left. You're you're
smashing it. Three
out of notes available. Okay. So they did
the same trick we did to them. Let's
remove the limits.
Right?
Do you think so? I'm I'm not
okay. Get note. Just do a get note.
One second. Let's let's first let's
so
Let's do a get note
just to be You want get note? Yeah.
Just to see what is going on here.
Let's see what's going on. It's a good
idea.
Okay. Scheduling disabled on work with two. Okay?
So we need to enable scheduling there.
And Alright. Let's
first look at the describe
to make sure this is the problem.
Describe
notes. Let's try the worker node. V
two.
Let's see.
Labels, annotation.
So how can you set a note that's
not schedulable in Kubernetes?
Actually,
I haven't tried. I always trying to make
them scheduled.
Are
you familiar with the carding command?
No.
The carding command? Do you?
Carden.
Sorry. Suppose to call you Shanks then coming
through.
No. It's okay.
No. I haven't tried that, but we can
play with it. Let's see.
Oh, I'm sorry. Did you I was just
sure I was just typing the command so
that you could get past my Oh, okay.
My funny person accent. But We have two
commands that to play with nodes, cordon and
uncordon.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
I get it. So just write anchor q
c t l,
I think note.
I haven't I know that it's a thing,
but I haven't used it.
Notes.
One second. What happened to my kubectl?
Is it only me, something like the kubectl?
What's wrong with your kubectl?
Okay. Sorry.
Okay. Kubectl. No. No. No. Kubectl
on core Cordon, U N C 0 R
D 0 N, uncordon.
Do you want me to write it?
Yeah. I don't wanna Okay.
I see it. Okay. Mark knows the schedule.
Nice. Okay.
And
it was work what was the name? Kong
dash worker dash two.
Kong
work dash
two.
You don't actually need to know it. Just
encarden call worker two. Yeah. Oh.
Ah.
At mission control. Mission control. Oh,
Call him.
Very mean. Right.
Keep CTL. David, remove all the mutating backups.
One
second.
Pip CTL.
Who's thought mutating Webhooks were a good idea?
Come on.
Yeah. What's it? There's a name. What's the
name for it? Mutating Webhook configurations.
Kubectl
mutating.
Oh, the I think something is not right
with the Yeah. Auto complete. Yeah. Oh, it's
auto complete. Okay. So
one
moment.
Open a new batch.
Yeah. Just run batch.
Although, you'll lose your export to config.
Oh, okay. So I'm okay with this. Here,
I I would come here, I'll do it.
Let's see. Kube
CTL.
Good.
That's the one.
No resources found.
Let's try the validation.
You have admission controller also in the API
server. You can Exactly. Static admission controllers.
Yeah. You can also
API. Let let's look at the like, let
yeah. Let's look at the API server configuration.
Where was it? It was in
it was I don't remember if it was
Etsy Kubernetes manifests.
Yeah. Yeah. Look at the Etsy data Kubernetes
manifests.
Okay. One second. It's always I'm sorry. Just
looking at the
Okay. And Just look at the Orest, yeah,
open it in Vim. Okay? So they will
going to edit it. I heard from David's
voice.
I'm sorry. Say again?
So just open for editing.
I'd like to see an episode of Clustard
where people just open Vem and have enough
plugins to just, like, navigate the directory system
and run cube control and never even bother
machine.
We want the controller manager or the API
server?
The API server.
Okay.
Okay. So you have this
what's
the name?
Enable boost
enable admission control no restriction.
Always
Plug in.
Always the nice that's bad. Right?
Yeah.
It doesn't move with the old node restriction.
Did we remove also the the node restriction?
No. Leave that one, please.
No. So
let me check out whether the whether the
API server has restarted.
I don't know if you can check. So
that that keeps c t l
get pods.
I can't believe because it's a oh, yeah.
Here it is. It's off right now. No.
Yeah. Give it a wee minute. It should
come back. Not a lot of teams would
have got a static admission controller. That was
well done.
Very nice. Yeah. It's probably, you know, these
are things that are, like, coincidences of your
last week.
I needed to wrote a paper about it,
and I didn't know it was beforehand also.
So some things are
just coincidentally.
So if it's taken too long, you can
restart the kubelet to speed it up a
wee bit.
Oh, yeah. Oh, there you go. Yeah. Okay.
So
Get pods. Okay.
Okay.
So this is still pending. Let's see why.
Well, you were you were trying to encode
and I know it. Yeah. There you go.
Yeah. Yeah.
So let's do that again. Encore.
Okay. That's better.
Now let's do let me get
node.
Okay.
This looks much better. It it it it
it's a little less complicated. Container creating. This
is better. Okay.
Let's make sure this works.
And
Comp it's stuck in container creating. And it's
Uh-oh.
Okay. Let's see what Probably pulling the image.
I think you're
maybe okay.
Let's let's so let's let's
look at this this container.
Describe.
Wow.
Really
annoying.
I'm sorry. Yeah. What was that command that
was run by team Kong, the complete command?
I think we're missing that.
Yeah. I I took this from kubectl. They
have their complete command, but I guess
clustered. Clustered.
Yep.
That's yeah. That's the command from Colin and
then the chat. Complete dash f underscore.
Oh, that's the f of the alias. That's
how they made it work.
Okay. Let's see.
So you have a ready replica?
Yeah.
I wanna look I just wanna make sure
that everything is over okay. Over here, like,
match labels Look at clustered.
There are no describe on this. Do describe
on the pod, please.
Okay. Sure.
Sorry.
Running. Okay. The pod is running. No. It's
running. Carl, local host. 30000. Go. Go. Go.
Okay. So do
we wanna check it's okay? Let's see if
we see the time the watch.
Yeah. We can we we can we can
check it properly. Yeah. Sure. Okay. Can can
you check it?
I would love to. So this is Kong
cluster.
Let me try the worker node. Sometimes it's
a control plane.
Yeah. Funny. Refuse.
Think think after the session, I'm taking the
letter s out of my keyboard. Alright.
So the state connection refused. So try Carl
local host 30000 just to make sure on
your side.
Okay.
And I'm not good.
I'm sorry? Yeah. Is that good? You're me.
Yeah. I missed it.
It's the best thing that someone is working
in the terminal. Right.
It's it's easier. Let's see what services are
we looking at. 30000
is what? 30000.
Yeah.
30000? Yeah.
Okay. One moment then.
Alright. We have a networking issue by the
looks of it. Yeah. And twelve minutes to
go.
Oh, that's nice. So
let's look into the service.
Get SBC.
It's there.
Okay. No port at 30,000.
Wait a second, David. Let's try something else.
Let's try to
do a
port forwarding.
Let's check where the issue is.
Okay. Can I I'm gonna look for the
I'm thinking here of something else? Let's just
check this. Okay?
Get all
my
cube
Sorry. Clustered.
Okay. So we have oh, there's an old
service. So the service, it doesn't have
right? Let's see. Let's look at take a
look at the service.
Describe.
This is so annoying.
Let's
look at the service.
You're missing a s. Yeah.
On describe.
Describe.
Oh, sorry. Thank you.
K. So the selector is clustered.
Okay. So this looks fine. Right? And it
has an endpoint?
No. Okay. Now let's see the port. It's
eighty eighty. The target port is also eighty
eighty. The north the node port is three
30,000.
It looks good. Endpoints
are eighty eighty.
Now let's do we wanna look yeah. Sure.
Now you take try the I will track
a port forwarding here.
Do we have the name of k. Let's
try.
TL port.
Thank you.
Colin, thank you. We tried that source, but
it didn't work for us for some reason.
Yes, Ben.
Yeah.
Oh, it won't work because we downloaded kubectl
and it's not the up into app version.
So it probably doesn't have what you need.
Right.
Maybe. I have I'm
sorry guys. I'm trying to copy paste here.
Okay.
I'm sorry for everyone. So let's try to
I don't know. 10,000
from here
to eighty eighty. Right?
This Mhmm. Is where it should go.
Okay.
So that's not good because
That doesn't look good.
That's all good. Good. That's good. Okay.
Let's try. Okay. So
So you can exec into the pod and
Carol is available.
Yeah.
That's a good idea. Let's try that.
Yeah. Minus minus Wait a second. You
yeah. But I think that
Okay. Do we
let's see what's blocking us.
So the there maybe
a network policy?
That's
interesting.
Members are our heads as well.
Mhmm.
You got eight minute.
Yeah. Wait a second. More problem is that
I cannot
x
error for okay.
So it looks like
problem connection with the
with the cubelets.
Yep. Port one zero two fifty is a
cubelet port. So something is strange there.
Let's try.
See, like, on every node you must.
Okay. So let's try the other node.
Let's try Bandtest on this one. Let's see
now. Yeah. Okay.
I know that. Perfect. I don't know
who's who can
David, I will join you another node.
I will open on Gong worker. What what
worker do you want? Where's the payload scheduled?
Wait a second. It should be
Oops. Sorry.
What what so sorry.
Yeah. Alright. Worker 2. Worker 2. Right. There
is no station on Worker 2. Please feel
free to go to activity, active sessions, and
join.
Okay.
There is a Worker 2. Oh, maybe it's
not gonna get a session on Worker 2.
No. There there is no worker. Worker
1 session is available. Worker two. No. I
cannot get to Worker 2.
Now both of them are running in Worker
2. You
you neither.
Because we can't access Worker 2, I will
encourage you to
record in it and move the workload to
another machine.
Yeah. Let may let's restrict maybe the the
let's restrict it to run-in worker one. Let's
try that.
What is it saying? So so should should
or should I cord but wait one second.
We started by Okay. Because I can't get
to worker one or worker two,
I am gonna help you out a little
bit here because if we can't get to
the machines, we can't fix them.
So Okay.
We're gonna card on marker one, card on
marker two Card on marker two. And we're
going to untaint
control
plan
one, and I can never remember the command.
So I'm gonna do it the hard way.
Tense.
Okay. Your workloads can now be scheduled on
the control plan.
Okay.
So, David
Yeah. Okay. D
w try to
let's go and check on where the pods
are.
Yep. One second. I'm just finding the right
the right thing in the YAML.
And
The workload should have been moved for you.
Oh,
okay. Let's see.
Okay.
So
let's check again.
And you need to concur.
So if that kubelet isn't able to speak
to the API server, you will have to
make a change to their deployment to force
a new one.
Oh, or
just delete the pod?
Well, the then we'll have to wait for
the five minute time out because the kubelet
isn't responsive.
Okay. So you're saying You you can try
it, but
I was thinking of deleting the replica sets.
Okay. Go for it. Let's try it and
then we'll make a decision.
Okay. Because that is, like,
delete it. I'm deleting Yeah.
Yeah. Delete them all. Go for it. That's
my favorite command.
Yeah.
Oh, and we have the other one. It's
a it's a demon set. Right? What is
the You don't have to worry about the
stateful set. Yeah. Avid's CV and get the
pod rescheduled.
There we go.
Yes. So do you need to do the
same for the status table set now. Yeah.
We need the same for the postgres.
Yeah. So let's delete it.
Delete button.
No. No. Delete.
There's a typo in the delete. Typo.
And while you're there, I I would also
I would also edit the the the deployment.
Already trying to we don't have much time.
Yeah. Let's get that version bumped.
Can yeah. Let's kubectl Okay. Kubectl edit
edit deployment
cluster.
I'm
sorry. I'm persistent.
You know, old habits.
Good habits also,
edit deployment. Clustered.
Enter and
down That's fine. Under from the
we want to be two.
Exit.
Yeah. So let's check on the pods.
Let's see if they did the same trick
we did.
Five seconds. Okay. It's running.
Alright. Let's test it. Okay. So let just
Connection refused. Do you wanna try the curl?
Yeah. Let's try the curl. Yeah.
Okay. So what do we see here? Felt
the connected database error
connecting to server connection time out.
Well, this is better. Okay. So so
concerns.
Somewhat.
So let's try to see, okay, what is
going with the with the post
Better based service.
It's connecting to the service, not the same
port.
Do you want?
David, do you want me to take over?
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. You can what do you
what do you suggest over here?
What?
No. I looked at the service of the
cluster. Maybe we should look also the service
There's no logs on the cluster pods. On
the postgres.
No.
No. There is no logs in postgres? I
would check postgres has logs. Yes.
Yeah. Let's try the postgres logs.
Okay. Server stopped.
There It looks good.
It's ain't good.
So this initialized
some functions.
Is it possible they changed the
similar to what we did with the config
file?
The config map? No. There's a create table
with an answer.
It does say your database is ready to
accept connection. I would maybe start looking at
the service.
No. But but I think okay. So this
is oh, okay. I guess so. Maybe.
Let's see if the service yep.
Okay.
So
Postgres is bound to app Postgres.
Oh, look at the port.
5431.
You see the port, Ben? Good catch. Yeah.
It's the wrong port.
Let yeah. Let's confirm just that the
our server is connecting.
Do you oh, 5432.
That's it. That should be 5432.
Yeah.
So
2.
Okay. Let's try to David,
do we need to restart the the
clustered or or or is it No. You
should be able to try the Yeah.
Yeah. We don't need to start. And done.
Fixed. Oh,
yeah. Let's try to check.
You there? Yep. V2 and V2.
Let's check for it.
Hold on. Can you please oh, yes. The
week I mean Yep.
Yeah. Okay.
You seem surprised.
No. There were many surprises over here.
Guys, you did a great job, Colin, and
Thank you very much.
Well done. That a
tricky one. Lot lots of evil work there
from Team Con. Yeah. But you you you
just worked through it one by one. Yeah.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Hey. Great job. Good catch for that port
as well.
You very much, David.
Well, thank you for joining me. Great work,
Diva. We're gonna cluster. Great work breaking the
cluster.
Yeah. Okay. So the reason I couldn't get
to it in the browser is because
oh, well,
USW was enabled on some of the notes,
but it's not a big deal. We were
able to curl the page and that's all
about us. So
thank you team Armour. I'm gonna let
you just get back to your day and
calm down, have a beer, have a coffee,
whatever you fancy. And thanks again. Have a
good one.
And to our sponsors, thank you very much
for Teleport and to Equinix Medal for all
their support. Thank you for watching. We will
see you all again next week. Have a
great day.